Gary let me start off with you on this  then balancing between fundraising and  building your business what do you look  for to see you um you know I'm concerned  a little bit with the culture of  celebrating the fundraise you know my  dad taught me that when you borrow money  it's the worst day of your life so I'm  very interested in the entrepreneurs I  like you know we didn't clap for Red  Rover because they didn't raise six  trillion dollars but I was sitting here  like good stuff  I just filtered myself so you know you  know what I'm looking for is people that  are not caught up in the excitement even  though I'm a hype man myself  I like the practicality of it all people  that understand how to turn a profit I  mean at the end of the day this is still  business right and so I'm looking for  real practical knowledge of how to  actually make money not necessarily  raise it